but first we begin with biden's feckless
policy as it relates to the war on
ukraine waged by vladimir putin he
dragged his feet on major sanctions he
dragged his feet on blocking russian oil
imports he dragged his feet on sending
the aid the lethal aid needed by ukraine
he dragged his feet on resupplying
ukraine's army with ammo javelins
stingers air defense systems and now
he's dragging his feet on the mig-29
fighter jets that ukraine desperately
needs that poland wants to give them he
vetoed it as a result ukraine is now
struggling to defend its skies and
thousands of innocent civilians are now
being murdered with russian bombs every
single day that joe biden is dithering
and waiting means more innocent men
women and children will die how many
more mass graves do we need to see
before we recognize that he's targeting
civilians now we're also witnessing a
modern-day genocide at the hands of an
evil murdering thug and why some people
defend them i have no idea but as
speaker gingrich who will join us in a
moment points out quote biden says no to
ukraine zielinski and keeps america in
the back seat so make no mistake what
happens in ukraine will have
consequences all over the world and you
better believe that other hostile
regimes like china the mueller's in iran
they're watching all
all while joe is forging ahead with this
idiotic new nuclear deal with iran still
being negotiated believe it or not by
russia and china how does that make
sense or as the national review put it
quote biden caves on sanctions over
russia's war crimes against ukraine to
preserve russia's sponsorship of
terrorist iran's nuclear program by the
way putin may get a 10
billion nuclear facility that he builds
in iran out of this deal according to
reports so an important question tonight
how can anyone on earth actually at this
moment
be trusting russia to broker a deal with
the iranians and our country
i cannot emphasize enough this is
madness this is insanity on a whole new
level but back to russia's invasion now
if ukraine is able to win this war it
will be in spite of joe biden and it's a
big if but the benefit would be
america's enemies hopefully we'll start
thinking twice before waging future
conflicts that i doubt that's going to
be the outcome because they see a weak
frail cognitive mess and joe biden they
don't see the smartest person in kamala
harris and nancy pelosi has her own
cognitive struggles and now more than
ever we need the policy of reagan and
trump and that's peace through through
strength and again i'm not talking about
starting world war three under no
circumstances should america ever put a
single boot on the ground should we at
all ever enforce a no-fly zone that's a
non-starter we should have learned a lot
in the last 20 years if not the last 60
years we cannot and will not be the
world's police force and i have said
this for days joe biden needs to get off
his ass and get ukraine those migs let
poland give them the migs and anything
else they need militarily they seem very
willing and able and capable of
defending themselves with the right
equipment and instead of joe's veto of
the poland migs he needs to get out of
the way and let every country do what
they believe is the right thing to do
this is europe it's their backyard they
should have a greater sense of urgency
over the us let's be clear this won't
escalate into russia's invasion into a
global conflict now let me just let me
give you a little history here during
the korean war the vietnam war maybe you
don't know this the soviet union at the
time they supplied north korea and north
vietnam with dozens of mig fighter jets
and by the way didn't lead to a world
war didn't lead to a nuclear holocaust
russia already set the standard for migs
and unfortunately the biden
administration doesn't seem to have a
firm grasp on history or foreign policy
now we are being led by truly
incompetent people stupid people this is
bad for the world it is bad to have a
weak united states president but today
the president took time out of his busy
schedule to reassure we the american
people that he's not stupid
see if you believe him you decide
let's be father from about to sin
i uh
well i just want you to know i may be
irish but i'm not stupid i married
dominic giacopa's daughter
that's so reassuring isn't it now
despite what we just heard i can assure
you that being irish and stupid is no
correlation it is st patrick's day even
though joe biden is both now over on
capitol hill it's even worse today nancy
pelosi made a valuable contribution to
ukraine with a dramatic reading of a
poem written by u2's bono although she
didn't quite say bono take a look what
you saw yesterday was history later at
the lunch just maybe you might want to
watch i'm going to be reading a poem
written by bono about ukraine which you
might find interesting but in sorrow and
fear that's when saints can appear
to drive out those old snakes once again
and they struggle for us to be free
from the psycho in this human family
ireland sorrow and pain is now the
ukraine
and saint patrick's name is now zawinski
wow all right despite what it might seem
not everyone in the democratic party has
been in the washington swamp for 150 000
years in fact they actually take their
marching orders from this new person the
real speaker of the house nancy pelosi
is speaker in name only take a look at
this we have a crisis of missing and um
and murder indigenous and black women in
the united states
today i want to discuss part of this
crisis that is all too often overlooked
but whose evidence shows that there's a
very meaningful connection here the
correlation between fossil fuel
extraction sites and abductions and
murders of indigenous women across the
united states
fossil fuels abductions and murders of
indigenous people
okay congresswoman aoc and a few other
low climate cult eco-socialists in
congress they're calling the shots now
in the democratic party that's why joe
biden won't drill and frack and do the
things that we could do to be energy
independent he's a coward that is now
refusing to stand up to that person her
squad and the entire democratic new
green deal radical socialist party that
he's leading as a result low
middle-income americans they are
suffering severely economically 40-year
high in inflation joe caused that joe
biden doesn't seem to care about those
americans middle-class joe that's all a
schtick it's a lie because if he cared
he would make enter make energy
independence a top priority he inherited
it from donald trump joe only seems to
care about himself and his family joe
biden is not a leader i doubt he knows
today is thursday he's a self-involved
career politician basically taking
talking points from his staff and of
course he loves the power and the wealth
and always has and always will hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else